who have you pranked
I'm not telling everyone
we mostly just
just prank random people and my mom's
friends okay
um okay speaking of mothers and
daughters writing this book this
beautiful book that you have put out
into the world
so
perfect how did you feel about your mom
writing this book
it's been extremely emotional just
I talk about things in this book that
I've never told my closest friends my
family
no one so she read it and she's just
been
really sad we were talking about it the
other day and she was just crying
saying I had no idea that what you went
through and it just broke her heart and
with my mom we've never been closer and
being an adult now and just seeing
especially being a mom just how
protective I already am
and my parents were lied to and they
thought that I was being sent to a
normal boarding school but these places
deceived them and that's why I've been
using my voice to make change and we've
changed laws in eight states so far I
mean that's incredible
um I I heard a story from the book which
is that Adam Sandler had a movie called
big daddy where you tell the story about
the sunglasses
well in the movie he gives a little boy
sunglasses and tells him whenever he's
feeling scared to put them on and he'll
be invisible
and for me I'm such a shy person but
when I put all my sunglasses I feel Not
Invisible but
more safe I guess not invisible but
Invincible Invincible yeah I like that
yeah now the last time we were together
in person we were at Britney's wedding
wow what a what a wild lovely beautiful
night that was
[Applause]
[Music]
so I mean do you know how many memes are
on that photo we're the last supper
we're like we're we're every skin cream
the memes are amazing so amazing did you
ever think that moment would go so crazy
viral well so iconic
it it really is
it really is so fun I loved it Brittany
looked so gorgeous
um okay your life in pictures
seeing the trajectory Looking Through
the Looking Glass from the past present
you know and into the future are you
proud of Who You Are
extremely proud feel that I've been
through so much in life and
just feel just really Brave and just
reading and like looking at my book and
just the life that I've lived it's just
been
a lot but I survived is there anything
that you would change
feel that everything in life happens for
a reason
and I believe that maybe God made me go
through what I went through in life and
gave me this special gift so one day I
could be the hero I always needed when I
was a little girl
[Applause]
[Music]
and then you know you're like okay I
didn't get to come to your neon Carnival
birthday like and the dinner party like
how do I keep partying and having some
fun because you seem to be doing it all
you're on Capitol Hill you're a mom
you're writing you're an advocate you're
also still sliven how do I Slim
seriously Paris how do I slip I'll teach
you how to slow it's a movement and a
lifestyle
I mean like you are a sliver like I just
feel like it's in your heart you're a
wildflower you're a sliver you know I am
I crazy but I am convinced that like in
the Disco era and even into the 80s 90s
like dancing made us generally happier
as a society I would love to like Camp
Studio 54 is just sitting there empty
like should we go take it over and like
buy it and like turn it back into it
living studio living Studio 54. I need
to dance all I want to do is dance let's
like start a Dance Movement I mean you
do it with your like DJing and you're
such a good that you're on like a neon
zebra one minute are you like
How's that gonna work if you're like on
a neon Carnival like DJing you know with
your like huge crowds like it's like
Coachella Ibiza like whatever is Phoenix
coming on your hip and going with you or
is he staying home that night
he definitely won't be on stage with me
for that I wanted to be able to travel
with him but he definitely won't be
coming in the club it's it's funny
because I'm like you know we have to
take our kids on our journey but I want
their journey to be like different than
mine so I'm always trying to find the
balance
I love you so much
thank you everybody Paris the Memoir is
available right now and it is so full of
incredible insights and details it is
just it's everything just like you we'll
be right back
thank you
[Music]